pope francis has arrived in baghdad at
the start of a historic four-day tour
of iraqi it's the first time a pope has
ever visited the country
the 84 year old head of the catholic
church touched down in the capital
an hour ago there are heightened fears
over security and a nationwide
coronavirus curfew
francis will meet with political and
religious leaders
and visit the former islamic state
stronghold mosul
counter-terror measures have been beefed
up after a spate of rocket and suicide
bomb attacks
in recent weeks
for more on this historic visit i'm now
joined by dw religious affairs
analyst martin garc martin why is the
pope visiting the country
now i think the main
interest of the vatican is to shed light
on
on a conflict i mean a situation for the
christian community which has been
essentially eclipsed by sort of a whole
series of other crises
that that have captured uh international
attention
so you know much in the usual way that
this pope
travels to places to highlight an issue
he's doing that now in in iraq where you
know the christian community has been
under enormous pressure
for the last few years i mean in a
region that has been in constant
conflict for the better
part of 20 25 20 years 25 years
and the numbers of the earth community
have
dwindled from 1.4 million believers or
faithful to
somewhere in the order of 250 000.
so uh on these pictures uh we're seeing
many people welcoming francis in baghdad
today and the pope also wants to
celebrate a mass with thousands of
believers during a worldwide
pandemic is that considered to be a good
idea
well there's been a lot of criticism but
i think that what we're seeing uh in
this images is precisely the problem
um that you know the vatican has to some
degree swept aside which is idea that
you know even with the best of
intentions governments cannot really
offer full control
of crowds and essentially when you have
something of this magnitude
which is the faith the first visit of
the pope uh
to you know a country that has been to
some degree
uh in political isolation and only based
on on the current
health crisis obviously you're bound to
have a lot of people circulating uh
and you know with very little capacity
to control them
so there is the the concern the third
concern obviously that
uh you know particularly the mass which
could attract uh
thousands of people this coming sunday
uh in the north of the country could
really become
a super spreader event uh but you know
the vatican takes
the position that is important to be out
there with the people
and this is the way in which they're
trying to fulfill that
what they see as their mission martin
stay with us um the country is a home to
some of the
oldest continuous christian communities
in the world but the
numbers of christians have dropped
dramatically in recent years
before we come back to you martin let's
have a look at their history
in the country vatican and iraqi flags
going up for pope francis's visit
people here are working hard to fix
everything up before he arrives
paving the roads fixing street lights
and setting up crowd control barriers
expectations are high
we hope for this to be a successful
visit and that it will help this
injured country when his holiness the
pope visits any place
there are a lot of positive outcomes
from his visit
church sits on the nineveh plain in iraq
home to some of the earliest christian
settlements
centuries before islam established
itself across the middle east
over time iraq became home to one of the
world's most diverse christian
communities
featuring catholic chaldean armenian
orthodox protestant as well as other
branches of christianity
we are sending a message to the pope and
to the world
that we are here we the christians
are remaining on our land our roots are
here
it is impossible to leave the homeland
that embraced us
there were as many as an estimated 1.4
million christians in the country at the
start of the iraq war
in 2003. sectarian conflict drove most
of them away
the pope's visit is supposed to send a
message of support
but he'll also meet with the head of
iraq's shiite muslim community
sending a different message that the
different faiths can
get along
so martin as we heard the report many
different
variants of christianity there in iraq
what does
what role does the head of the catholic
church really play for
all those different christians in iraq
today
well i mean every one of this every one
of these denominations
has been uh basically under enormous
pressure so i mean on the one hand
even though we can talk about different
communities and different different
denominations
uh you know for uh essentially the
forces that have been impinging
regularly
over the the space of uh of christian
practice in in iraq
uh of course what they see is mostly
just
christians what that means is that the
pope
coming to the area is not really just
sort of something that
will impact sort of the standing of
catholics
in the region or in the country but will
actually go beyond that
and i think that it can be rightly seen
as presenting the case
uh for the christian community as a
whole
i think that for this vatican the
question of inter-religious relations
especially with with the muslim world
has been very very important
um and i think that in the in the
conditions in which a christian
community finds itself this uh
this gains uh obviously new new
relevance
dws religious affairs analyst martin
guck there thank you martin
you